alors sur la fraude non sur la frude
sociale ce PLFSS comme le PLF d'ailleurs
propose déjà un certain nombre de
mesures importantes mais mais je vais
revenir parce que je je je suis moi
disposé à travailler avec vous à écouter
vos propositions parce que je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin mais quand
même rappelons-nous que nous avons dans
le PLF le PLFSS une mesure pour mieux
sécuriser le crédit d'impôt Service à la
Personne les prélèvements de cotisation
sur les travailleurs des plateformes que
les caisses de sécurité sociale se sont
engagées sur un recrutement de 1000 TP
d'ici 2027 dédié à la lutte contre la
frotte sociale moi je pense qu' il en va
de notre cohésion sociale et donc il y a
un véritable effort et une orientation
qui a été fixée aux caises de sécurité
social de renforcer la lutte contre la
fraude on introduit dans le PLFSS un
délit d'incitation à la fraude sociale
par parallélisme avec ce qu'on fait dans
le champ fiscal d'ailleurs en disant
ceux qui vivent qui font de la promotion
de la frotte sociale c'est un coup de
Can dans notre contrat social et il faut
pouvoir traiter la fraude à la source il
faut qu'on soit intransigent sur ce
sujet-là et donc chacune des caises de
sécurité sociale à des plans d'action
certains même des moyens renforcés pour
mieux lutter contre la fraude j'ai
installé madame la la rapporteur
générale y était autour du Conseil
d'évaluation de de la fraude en disant
il faut qu'on évalue mieux on a cert des
rapports de la Cour des comptes mais
c'est parfois difficile
d'évaluer correctement le montant de la
fraude et pour être efficace dans notre
politique de lutte contre la fraude il
faut qu'on y voit plus clair et c'est
tout le mandat que nous avons fixé aux
administrations dans le cadre du Conseil
d'évaluation de la fraude et on
reviendra
avant non il manque honnêtement il
manque on a des des trous dans la
raquette très importants et et
d'ailleurs le l'assurance maladie était
là pour mieux évaluer le le montant de
la frotte il y a un travail à conduire
et je suis par ailleurs ouvert à toutes
les propositions des par parlementaire
sur ce sujet-là on a mis dans le PLF
dans le PLFSS moi je suis prêt à porter
un projet de loi dédié à la lutte contre
la fraude si on voit qu'il manque des
dispositifs législatifs pour le muscler
et je Seris très très très très à
l'écoute des propositions de la
Commission des sénateurs sur sur ce
sujet-là